welcome everyone to our final Schulman
lecture of the semester and is also our
final Shulman seminar after the lecture
the students in the audience are
overjoyed I'm sure last week at classes
it's wonderful to see all of you here
the Shulman seminars and lectures as
many of you will know from professor
xanto's and i saying this in past
lectures were founded in 2007 and they
are they were founded with the brief of
linking the sciences and the humanities
across campus specifically to encourage
and sustain dialogue an intellectual
collaboration across the proverbial
divide between the two cultures the
Shulman lectures are presented under the
auspices of the Franke program in
science in the humanities which is made
possible by the generosity of Richard
and Barbara Frankie a bold and exciting
convergence of the Arts and Sciences the
series is fittingly named after Robert
Schulman who is in the audience
sterling professor emeritus of chemistry
molecular biophysics and biochemistry
senior research scientist and diagnostic
radiology and a founding fellow of the
Whitney and unwavering supporter of the
integration of science and the
humanities Bob Schulman truly in fully
embodies the spirit of the program
please join me in thanking professor
Shulman
[Applause]
so it gives us enormous pleasure to have
an Harrington joining us to deliver this
final lecture and Harrington is the
Franklin L Ford professor of the history
of science at Harvard where she is also
director of the undergraduate of
undergrads undergraduate studies in the
Department of history of science and for
three years now the faculty dean of
pforzheimer house which is the
equivalent of a head of college not that
Yale invented it professor Harrington
specializes in history psychiatry and
neuroscience and the other mind and
behavioral sciences which makes her as
you can imagine an ideal scholar
to bring our series on other Minds to a
close she received her PhD from Oxford
and held postdoctoral fellowships at the
Wellcome and at the University of
Freiburg before arriving at Harvard
where she has taught ever since her
famous Gen ed course on madness and
medicine has been a model for many such
courses including my own course on minds
and brains here at Yale in addition to
teaching professor Harrington has
chaired the Department of history of
science directed Harvard's
interdisciplinary mind brain and
behavior initiative and served in
various administrative and editorial
positions connected with her work on
minds and brains that work has included
thus far three books medicine mind in
the double brain rien chanted science
and the cure within a history of
mind-body medicine and currently
involves the fourth which I gather is
tentatively titled the biological
revolution in psychiatry what really
happened I won't read out the many
titles of volumes
she's edited or article she's written
except to mention that students in the
seminar connected with the course have
just read a piece she co-authored called
when mindfulness is therapy which is
related to though not the topic of her
talk today we couldn't be happier to
have an Harrington joining us today
please join me in welcoming her to
campus
[Applause]
so I company years old a band so I don't
have to lean I had not realized until
this introduction that the showman
lecture series and program was intended
to bring people from the humanities and
people in the sciences together and I
just think that's fantastic
you know and it might also be given that
it might be just helpful before I talk
to you about our love affair with
meditation and try to relate it to the
theme of a lecture series and other
minds suggest position I wasn't going to
do this with given what we're saying you
know position myself in relationship to
the material that I'm going to talk to
you about although I'm going to be
wearing a Nestorian hat for the purposes
of making I hope some sort of larger
analytic points we can talk about I have
a both research relationship and to a
certain extent a personal and collegial
relationship to a lot of the history
that I'm going to talk about today I
know a lot of the people that I'm going
to talk about today I like a lot of the
people but I'm going to talk about today
and I see it as part of my
responsibility as a critical humanist to
try to help them to understand how they
how I see the positioning of their
projects of the mindfulness revolution
of our love affair with meditation
within other histories and other stories
that may not be so self-evident to them
but that are really important if we all
want to do the best science and be the
best people and do the best practice if
we're practitioners that we can so I am
have called this Electra but our love
affair with meditation so I'm going to
actually tell it as a love story a love
story in four parts that arcs over about
50 years into our own time and I'm going
to do it not only because I think it's a
story that's
worth telling and worth remembering and
particularly for people who are younger
than 25 maybe quite unfamiliar and you
may just think your slice of this story
is all there is and it's good to know
that it isn't but also because
ultimately I want to land in a place
where we can talk about this overarching
question of the Shulman lecture series
this year namely other minds and what
meditation and particularly the changing
love story the evolving love story of
our meditation and us can say to the
bigger questions of other minds so I'm
going to tell my stories but and allow
the materials to prepare the argument
for me and then we can step back and
talk about things so so we start in a
place that some of the people who are
smiling in the back and are of an age to
have actually lived through it in an era
that I'm you know the counterculture the
60s an era when as people who lived
through this year may also remember or
particularly if you were young in this
era was marked by many things but the
thing that interests me most of the
purpose of this talk is its fascination
with all things Eastern Eastern with
Hinduism with Buddhism with Sufism with
things mystical with things non
judeo-christian because the view was
that the judeo-christian traditions were
ossified lacked experiential richness
and couldn't provide a satisfying path
for a new generation of young people who
are rejecting all sorts of established
institutions including the churches that
they might have been raised on I never
looking for alternatives so Allen walked
who was a
figure that a lot of people read in
those years made the point clear and
quite polemically that look if the
Christians group aren't going to give it
to these kids they're going to have to
go elsewhere now the next thing to say
is kind of important when they looked
east these discontented spiritually
hungry discontented spiritually hungry
generation one of the things to know is
that most of the time they were just
reading about it
it was books called books they you know
and you know people had their book a
very very few people if you had the
means and you were really really
committed maybe got on an airplane and
went to India I know a few who did or to
Thailand but these things would become
the teachers for later these people were
not meditating by and large and there
were really meditation centers or Zen
centers if that appealed yet to broad
popular note of ordinary people and then
LSD happens now LSD let's just you know
remember or maybe learn for the first
time LSD was a drug that was synthesized
in a laboratory
it was synthesized in the 1930s in a
laboratory in Switzerland and originally
LSD was believed to be interesting
because it created people said a
chemically induced temporary state of
schizophrenia it was interesting for
psychiatry because maybe it would teach
something about the biochemistry of
schizophrenia it was interesting for
certain therapists who gave LSD on an
experimental basis to alcoholics to
neurotic to children with autism so
particularly down at Bellevue Hospital
New York kids with given
LFC down there the military was
interested in LSD because they thought
maybe could be used as some sort of a
technology for brainwashing or could be
weaponized in some other way so how do
we end up here what happens is some of
the test subjects like Ken Kesey who
named you might know because he's the
author of the book the novel One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest ends up going
through a CIA funded study using LSD as
far well as mescaline and amphetamines
and is able to get his hands on some of
this and they and the drug goes rogue he
takes the drug and he gets inside his
psychedelic bus and he goes across the
United States in 1964 with his gang of
mischief visiting a friend for the Merry
Pranksters and they start turning on the
youth and over this period and very
short number of years
LSD turns from a drug of psychiatry and
science into a drugs of rebellion
political liberation and most important
for our purposes expanded consciousness
turn on tune in drop out who set back
you guys you you you're like we remember
you're like who who is that hmm
that was Timothy Leary yeah so that
became kind of the unofficial mantra of
the LSD the psychedelic revolution and
this development creates the condition
for a blending of what had originally
been two separate elements of the
sixties counterculture a drug that made
you high and older Eastern mystical
traditions that have long been supposed
to offer a path to enlightenment by the
early 1960s people are starting to ask
questions and by people I mean religious
dollars and psychologists serious people
are starting to ask questions about how
far the experiences that people were
having under LSD might actually be more
or less the same as the ones described
in all the Eastern mystical traditions
and by the mid-1960s it's kind of taken
as red so there was a kind of
ethnographic study that was carried out
by two journalists looking at the usage
of LSD on campus in the mid-1960s and
the kids talked about LSD and Eastern
mysticism and one said I thought in a
way they kind of summed up the consensus
it's instant then but if LSD is instant
then is then for some other kind of
meditative traditions equally a path to
some kind of LSD expanded consciousness
and it's clear that some people started
to hope that it would be that meditation
could get you high so here now let's
visit an ashram in New York City
reported by a journalist again in 1967
from the New York Times ashrams are now
spreading there's more and more than
people are more more interested in them
he visits an ashram in Brooklyn army
talks to one of the young women who he
sees practicing there and she says oh
gosh you know I had this great original
original experience when I took the LSE
but I never really came back so I found
this ashram and now I'm now I'm hooked
on religion I'm a better person so I
gave up the drugs and I adopt as I
started to meditate that's what she says
here's what her teacher says these kids
are exhibitionist they don't enter
discipline what I realize I mean you can
just imagine him sort of spluttering and
and she's like oh I love Swami and he
space this drug culture he says is very
dangerous they're not saying that
there's a connection between LSD and
drug go to the arts thinking of the
Swami doesn't think this is a sensible
way to connect it's the clients that are
making this connection and that's
drawing them into the ashram but notice
what he says about the discipline and
their lack of discipline because it
could help explain why the story of our
love affair with meditation then goes in
the directions that it does namely away
from the ashrams with all the hard work
and learning that they demanded of the
people who came there and towards a new
spiritual offering from the east that
seemed a lot more user-friendly known as
Transcendental Meditation or TM who's
heard of it who's used it so we can
maybe come back to back to that so it
comes to the shores of the United States
in person the very late 1950s it's
taught by this man the Maharishi Mahesh
Yogi from India its mantra based devant
derived from ancient Hindu Vedic
traditions but it's modernized for the
less disciplined kinds of appetites of
the young people in the West so it
didn't ask a lot of people 15 to 20
minutes a day twice a day is all you had
to do reciting a special mantra a secret
mantra allegedly customized to your
unique spiritual need and in return what
did TM promise you you remember
they've thank you so if promised you to
a first approximation a pathway to the
kind of expanded consciousness that
people were so hungry for in this period
it promised you bullets it promised you
God consciousness it promised you
experiences beyond the ordinary that
could only be experienced and not put in
two words and eventually it promised a
transformation of you as a person as a
whole into someone more peaceful more
creative more intelligent possibly even
but this was controversial even in the
movement you know possessed of
supernatural power there was a
levitating the flying Yogi's bit of TM
now prior to the 1960s or tofu disease
nineteen sixty four or five TM was a
pretty small thing when the Maharishi
spoke hundreds of people came not
thousands of people what begins to
change things is the fact that the
Beatles decides that the Beatles who
have been going through their own LSD
explorations in this period had been
done a lot of drugs we're feeling very
lost find the Maharishi and make him
their teacher they give up drugs they go
clean they claim to now be experiencing
clarity and heightened levels of
creativity
it's very public it's very widely
covered in the press a number of other
celebrities then come along they make a
very widely publicized and covered trip
to India with the Maharishi and with
that little um so that little catalyst
and we find
TM becoming the flavor of the moment it
because the preferred path to
psychedelic lifts without drugs and
everyone wanted to learn it and the
numbers here really tell the story so if
you look at the records kept by the
staff of the organization so that up
until 1966 only about a thousand people
in the United States had learned TM from
1966 until the early 1970s there's an
exponential growth culminating in the
initiation of almost 300,000 people into
the practice in a single year in the
early 1970s and monomi she's now being
invited to speak on TV shows he gives
interviews in 1967 the New York Times
writes this profile proclaiming him to
be the new guru of the Western world so
guys who are less than 25 years old I do
who among those of you who are left in
25 years old had ever heard of the
Maharishi Mahesh Yogi and who had never
heard of him so you know we forget
so things peak and then things change
the Beatles
fall out with the Maharishi the
counterculture kids start to get jobs
and get older and someone hasn't have to
cut their hair it's the 70s and if the
mood is different
we've got a war on drugs we've got a
different sensibility the Maharishi and
his organization needs that they need to
realize they need to ship strategies and
to woo new kinds of customers and so by
the 1970s the people signing up for TM
are no longer the kids who were an LST
once and now are looking for bliss
through meditation they're businessmen
they're housewives they don't want the
list necessarily they may not even know
what bliss is what do they want so look
at the title of this New York Times
article I know I keep using the New York
Times a lot but it just is you know it's
a it's a data point that I'm it's not
the only evidence but um but still
tuning down with TM so the mantra of the
psychedelic years was turning on
dropping out tuning in people don't want
to tune in anymore they want us to down
they want to just get some peace of mind
and TM promises them peace of mind
and so we find ourselves on the
threshold of a new emerging stage in our
love affair with meditation one in which
we are loving it not because it's
offering us so much a path to bliss and
heightened states of consciousness but
because it seems to promise us a
technology a technique a practice to
relax to become less stressed to become
more peaceful and we knew in the 1970s
that we needed to become a lot less
stressed because we knew we were living
through an epidemic of stress stress
linked disorders we knew that stress was
a uniquely American problem a toxic
physiological response to the relentless
rat race of American life we knew that
it led to anxiety and ulcers and high
blood pressure and most significant and
important of all heart attacks the
classic type-a personality the old
stressed-out executive who can't relax
who can't stop working who drives drives
drives himself until he finally drops
dead of a heart attack becomes the
archetypical kind of tragic hero of
1970s behavioral psychology and into
this space where connections between
stress
modern life and heart disease emerges a
important figure for our story a man
named Herbert Vincent Vincent a
cardiologist
Benson believes as more and more people
were that stress is a risk factor for
heart disease and he had been
particularly been interested in the
possibility of teaching people ways to
lower their blood pressure which is a
risk factor for heart attack using new
biofeedback techniques the new
biofeedback techniques that were popular
in this period and even working with
monkeys and trying to see whether or not
they could use biofeedback for the blood
pressure
able to go down and then a group of TM
practitioners of kids who had practiced
TM come to him they've heard about the
experiment and they say you need to
study this monkey study people study us
we don't need machines we can lower our
blood pressure just through this
practice and he so I know her pretty
well and I've listened him tell this
story a lot and he talks about now I
don't want a this crazy stuff I'm not
the you know the all this Eastern flaky
stuff I mean look at him he is not part
of the obviously evidently part of this
or the counterculture scene he didn't
know anything but Eastern religions
finally he said okay okay but come up
the back stairs because this is likely
to ruin my career and they do and he
studies them and there he is in Boston
Massachusetts on the other side of the
country over in the much more
counterculture still Berkeley California
I'm sorry Los Angeles California there's
a both of the counterculture but
California a guy named Keith Wallace
Robert Keith Wallace had just interested
in CM and decided that he wanted to do
his dissertation in psychology on the
physiology of tm-2 recruited college
students who taken one of the courses he
hooks them up to various measuring
machines he asked him to meditate and he
finds a whole bunch of physiological
changes reduction and oxygen consumption
reduction and resting heart rate changes
in skin resistance and he's not very
interested in any of those he's not very
interested in those because he's after a
bigger prize and the bigger prize has to
do with the this this quote what he also
finds or believe themselves to find is
that people innovative TM when you do an
EEG while they're in the state undergo a
shift in consciousness that
had never been seen before in psychology
a fourth state of consciousness I guess
the other three states are sleeping
waking and written maybe I'm dreaming
yeah thank you so this would be a fourth
state why is this important
it's physiological evidence of the
potential claim of TM that it's open
it's a method for expanded consciousness
it's a method to get high it's a method
to enter into a different state and book
where he publishes this article we're
not talking about something sort of on
the margin it's published in science the
flagship Journal of American science in
1972 Benton's back in Boston read this
article learn to the work invites
Wallace to come to Boston and
collaborate with them and they do the
studies again and what happens well they
do discover that there are these
physiological changes that seem to be
suggestive of a physiological quieting
decrease the metabolism breathing rate
brain weight brainwave frequency what
Benson does not believe is that there's
any special state that is involved here
in fact he's adamant about this all he
thinks that he and while it have
discovered is what effectively amounts
to a reversal of the stress response
what he calls eventually a relaxation
response now politically this is a
really big deal because the Maharishi
had been really excited that a Harvard
cardiologist was now studying TM
practitioners he now breaks from the
Maharishi he tells me I should I don't
think in my neck I know that because the
Maharishi actually invited him to live
with him in the Himalayas embolism
you keep doing this important research
and but you know breaks lives of
Maharishi he breaks with Wallace he
insists that the mantra that was
supposed to be the special uniquely
customized word given only to you could
be anything I use asking what about
bubblegum
he said bubblegum find it anything and
he great does he breaks all all these
people and he just leans hard on the
health message what we're dealing with
really and why we should love meditation
really is to with that it's a natural
universal technology that you needn't
connect to any specific Eastern
traditions of any sort for creating
clinically desirable physiological
effects namely turning off the stress
response it's a technique to create what
comes to be known as stress reduction so
when he publishes his book in 1975 there
were endorsements from a professor at
Harvard Business School from another
cardiologist from a general practitioner
from a stress research not a whisper of
anything Eastern anywhere and this is
one of the blurred on the back
he's taken the nonsense out of
meditation they say and for a while this
resonates we learned to love this much
more pared down much more every day much
more matter-of-fact form of meditation
the same New York Times journalist who
tried TM and thought they were going to
give her a housewife a mantra like their
rather than own because she's just a
housewife and who just wanted to tune
down rather than to turn on also visits
Benson and in the end proclaims him the
new face of meditation Benson shown it's
just I thought
aspirin that's why we should love
meditation relaxation stress reduction
rather than meditation becomes the
reference point becomes the buzzword so
much so that by the early 1990s when a
doctor at Harvard named David Eisenberg
does a 1-point a very well-known of
survey of health habits and particularly
health habits around usage of
alternative so-called alternative
methods he finds that so-called
relaxation techniques are top of the
list you can see the other things that
were sort of included
and this demystified secular reframing
of meditation as just a form of stress
reduction tips us into where we have to
go next and which will now start to feel
like a world we now recognize it's more
like our world but it really is only
existed since the 1980s a cheap person
still very prominent and well-known
Danny was interested in mindfulness is
Jon kabat-zinn in 1979 he looked more
like this then now he's a man probably
in his 70s he's a PhD student at MIT in
molecular biology but he had his own
eastward journey he'd gone to India he
does a serious yogic and meditation
practitioner and she decides that he
doesn't want to get a PhD in molecular
biology he wants to teach this to the
world but how do you do it he goes to a
clinic at UMass Medical School down in
Worcester Massachusetts and he proposes
that he can set up an on-site program
that would be targeted to people that
doctors basically had given up on people
with chronic pain people with other
kinds of chronic disabilities medicine
can see much more fun but I can help
them is what he says and and they let
him do it and what he says is um I'm not
a doctor I'm not a therapist I'm not
trying to fix anybody I'm not trying to
cure anybody what I'm going to do he
says it's change people's relationship
to their suffering and because and you
go to a hospital because suffering
alleviation suffering is a basic precept
of people who follow a Buddhist path
Jon kabat-zinn has along done and you go
to a hospital because there's so much
suffering there so you start you start
there so I'm going to change the
relationship to their suffering by
teaching them to cultivate what then
comes to be called a mindful
non-judgmental acceptance of the whole
catastrophe his first book full
catastrophe living what does that mean
it is a strange title you think for a
book that you might think is all about
peace and relaxation it's not meant to
be about that at all it's meant to be
about waking up to the good the bad and
the ugly and discovering that if you
walked into that and without judging it
your attitude towards the reality of
your life might shift you might become
less afraid of your pain you might
become less depressed by your disability
because you could see it then in the
context that also saw how much is right
with you as well as how much is wrong
with you and again I will just say
because I've been sort of doing this all
through that I know cavesson as well and
I went through one of these programs and
so some of what I'll be saying about him
is partly come from having known him for
15 years and I like him a lot he calls
this program as many of you know
mindfulness based stress reduction MBSR
but he doesn't really believe this is
anything to do with stress reduction not
for a minute
it's hard work it's not always fun you
had to get your tushie on a cushion and
do it whether you liked it or not you
had to wake up to the truths of your
life straight on and that could be quite
stressful there was a running joke for
years at with them at the Worcester Mass
medical clinics that it's really
stressful to go through this program so
why did he call it a stress reduction
program because people remembered the
counterculture years people remember the
earlier of reasons why we loved
meditation because we thought it was
going to give us bliss and associated
with all these flaky new agey monks with
shaved heads and he said I had to use
stress reduction
first of all Benson was the only way to
get it in the door Benson had already
created a framework in which it was
acceptable to talk about stress
reduction it wasn't acceptable to talk
about meditation so since he's talking
about this looking back in 19 2011 I
just had to find some way to get it in
and I couldn't talk about the real deep
roots at that point of the practice but
if I could just get it in and they would
experience it then we could go from
there
but this having this decision having
been made the program MBSR found itself
with a bit of a marketing dilemma
because it's not really stress reduction
he's not trying to fix anybody so it's
not therapy it's still though carried
out on a clinic it still something good
for people and you don't want to talk
about what you're really doing because
it might scare people away so you don't
want to mention Buddhism you don't want
to mention any of those other things so
how do you talk about it so
in 1993 kabat-zinn is featured in a very
very widely viewed series that was
hosted by Bill Moyers on PBS called
healing on the mind and you see him
talking to Bill Moyers who's this very
folksy you know front porch kind of guy
who you know seems like you know like
doesn't order you know just an ordinary
guy that you can relate to and he's in
this place and he's talking to cab
Athena cab Athena's talk and acting
what's it all about
and cavesson talks like this growing
strength and wisdom bring healing into
your life even if I mean it's beautiful
what he's saying but you watch the video
and you see more sort of squinting and
you see them sort of nodding and you
seem sort of squinting and when it comes
time to describe this segment of the
program for general audiences when they
bring it to television they describe
kabat-zinn
as quote a therapist who is treating
patients without any drugs of surgery
because you can understand that and
effectively that much simpler
understanding becomes the default way of
making sense of MBSR for most people it
makes sense
it didn't seem paradoxical it allowed
also people to locate mindfulness based
stress reduction inside a Market Basket
of other so-called wellness treatments
of the late 1980s and 90s like
acupuncture massage and yoga and energy
medicine and Pilates and all these other
things that were people were doing to
improve their well-being so mindfulness
based stress reduction MBSR is turned
into therapy and turned into therapy we
then have a
a moment in which it in the 1990s it
begins to go more and more mainstream
and we see efforts to test its
effectiveness initially for a lot of
mental health conditions depression
anxiety eating disorders PTSD
suicidality we see more and more
patients testifying to its effectiveness
for them we see more and more clinicians
now interested in finding ways to
incorporate it into their toolkits we've
seen on clinical trials we see news that
we need to see new scales and cavesson
is kind of in the middle of all this and
he's both encouraging it and saying well
well actually it isn't that and he's
encouraging it but actually it is in
fact but the momentum the cultural
momentum of turning MBSR into medicine
continues apace and even deepens further
to the point that people now start to
ask whether or not it might be good not
just for mental health but also for
physical health maybe can boost immune
system functioning contree allergies if
skeleton actually did a study himself on
psoriasis and mindfulness heart health
so we see in in 2014 that look we need
to take this this is medicine we need to
subjected to the same kind of serious
scrutiny that we didn't create any other
form of medicine it's proven itself to
the degree that it's now time to welcome
it into the fold
the story's not quite over because each
story that I've told before paved the
way for a further evolution of our
evolving love affair with meditation so
too did the medicalization of
mindfulness paved the way and
particularly the growing interest in the
physiology of mindfulness paved the way
to a final vision of meditation in which
it's not so much about getting us well
and more about transforming us and
finally I'm getting to other minds
making us new better people now I'm to
make sense of this we need to think
about a larger set of trends in American
culture over the past several decades to
take treatments particularly drugs that
had been used or developed initially for
specific medical disorders and
repurposing them for the purposes of
enhancing us even if we don't have those
disorders so prozac which was originally
developed as a new kind of
antidepressant with fewer side effects
than the previous tricyclics
antidepressants by the mid-1990s there
is a kind of general recognition that
gets articulated by a guy named Peter
Kramer in a book listening to prozac
that a lot of people are taking Prozac
not because they need clinical criteria
for major depression but because they
like the way it makes them feel peppier
and we're confident it's a kind of it
gives them a kind of personality
makeover and that's why they're on the
drug and that's why by the way I'm still
prescribing the drug even from my
patients who don't be clinical criteria
for depression viagra
viagra has recently developed to deal
with high blood pressure much more
profitable when it was targeted to
enhance the sexual lifestyles of older
people Botox
originally developed to treat muscle
spasms becomes the device to smooth
wrinkles rejuvenate aging faces drugs
like ritalin to treat ADHD in kids the
kids grow up they go to college they
have their prescriptions they start
using Ritalin as study drugs to enhance
their functioning so this is a bigger
world of using medical technologies to
enhance oneself and we want that but we
also kind of despise ourselves for it
and we think we should be more resilient
and we think we should depend on
ourselves and we still think we should
be natural and then they're not using
crutch of drugs and all the possible art
side effects and injections so and then
there's mindfulness but mindfulness is
medicine without drugs
mindfulness is medicine without
injections without surgery
we already know that it's effective in
relieving depression and anxiety so why
can't we use it also in the ways that we
also have used Prozac in the past to
help you know stockbrokers who might
otherwise get really really stressed out
by the ups and downs of the stock market
whole help them the whole study so they
can make a big profit why not use it to
enhance your sex life why not use it to
improve your athletic performance and
these are real questions why not if it
works why not there's no judgement here
but it goes someplace else and this is
the place where I'll wrap up my kind of
excursion through time when we finally
go for broke and say not just use it to
enhance this aspect of our functioning
or this other aspect of our functioning
but to literally sculpt us into the good
people that we all really want to be and
here you know we there's a new buzz in
the brain sciences that undergirds this
new conversation about a new kind of
transformation of enhancement the brain
we used to think that by the time you're
an adult you're stuck with the brain you
have and it can't change now we know we
were wrong the brain is really really
plastic you don't have to settle for the
brain you were born with you can right
through your adult life rewire yourself
the brain can modify itself it's never
too late to change
and mindfulness meditation sometimes
were generally but mindfulness is the
word that people use now even though
actually some of not all the studies use
mindfulness techniques but it's the
buzzword mindfulness becomes a
technology for rewiring the brain to
help people become that new version of
themselves that better person this is a
book that comes out in the early 2000 by
Sharon Begley she attended a meeting
with the Dalai Lama of Tibet and some
other neuroscientists on brain
plasticity and wrote this book the
consequence of learning about the
interfaces between meditative practice
and neuroscience at that meeting also
was a friend of mine named Richie
Davidson who has been more prominent
probably than anyone else
in articulating this idea of meditation
or mindfulness as a means to rewire the
brain and therefore transform the mind
which he was also at this meeting with
Sharon Begley and the Dalai Lama and
right about the time that Sharon baby
comes out with this book Richie had come
out with a study that for a brief period
of time really dominated a lot of
neuroscience press at least in some
circles Lisa seemed that way to me they
had carried out a study at the
University of Wisconsin on the effects
of meditation not on ordinary people but
on Extra Ordinary people they had
studied the brains of monks from the
Tibetan Buddhist tradition who had a
very very advanced practice who had been
on retreat for minimum three years
practicing eight hours a day they
brought them to Wisconsin and they
published and they examined
but the memorize put them with multiple
multiple hundreds of electrodes and they
concluded in a paper that was published
in the Proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences that the brains of
these advanced practitioners were
different from the brains of the rest of
us in two ways the left prefrontal area
of the brain was metabolically much more
active then it is in rest of us and this
is significant because Ritchie believes
and argues that the left prefrontal area
of the brain is associated with positive
effect and the reduction of negativity
it's the happy side of the brain and
it's much more metabolically active in
these folks but particularly astounding
when these monks were asked to meditate
on compassion their brain activation
levels were unlike any that ever been
seen in healthy subjects particularly or
specifically the gamma waves which are
high-level beta waves was 30 times as
strong as those seen in the control so
you can look at so this is us these are
the monks
so Davidson goes on to call one of these
months again a man I know matthieu
ricard who he had collaborated with on
the original monk study and continued to
work with for in the years after he goes
on to call him the happiest man in the
world in 2012 and matthieu ricard
is called the happiest man in the world
not because he had self-reported huge
levels of happiness or because other
people said my god that guy is so happy
he was a happiest men the world because
his brain scans revealed a particular
profile that suggested what Ricci was
called abnormal and abnormally large
capacity for happiness and reduced
propensity towards negativity what do
they say here in this article the half
of the largest capacity for happiness
ever recorded now the two records would
go on to say that well I think it's kind
of a you know public relations stunt a
little bit but you see that he then goes
on to say well you know or goes on to
reinforce the big message to be drawn
from this namely but on the other hand
meditation completely changes your brain
and therefore changes what you are I am
NOT the record I would have been if I
had not become a Tibetan monk if I
hadn't done the practice I am NOT that
person I am a new person so
so where does this leave us so I have
some obvious things to say and then
maybe a few less obvious things so the
obvious things first we really want
mindfulness we really we love meditation
or many of us do we don't always want it
we don't always love it for the same
reasons it isn't always the same thing
and when you look back over the arc of
time what you see and I'm actually
struck by how much this is the case you
see the ways in which the things we love
track in a really striking way a range
of other histories and the values and
fears and needs that are channeled
within these other histories we can
understand the history of America's love
affair with meditation without attending
to the histories of counter cultures the
drug culture the culture of stress
stress reduction the Wellness movements
and our restless hunt for self
enhancement but this is supposed to be a
contribution to a conversation you've
been having all semester on the nature
of other minds and so let me say
something about about this and what I
take away from the sort of his start
histories that I've accounted that's
relevant to this so all the meditative
traditions that we've fallen in love
with over the years share two things
they share a belief in the malleability
of our mental cells and they share a
certain vision of a mind faith or self
state that were meant to aspire to each
of them offers us a kind of aspirational
mind a mind to which we should aspire
and meditation is that practice the
technique the path to arriving at that
aspirational mind maybe we never get
there or maybe we think we do but
sometimes the path that were on is
conceived as largely reparative in other
words it's about getting back to the
self we really are always were but that
has been obscured by our pain or by our
stress or by our anxiety so we can
become less stressed less depressed less
anxious we can reveal the self that is
our better selves but it's also our real
self our essential self it's only been
obscured by our disease or by our
unhealthy lifestyles other times the
aspirational self and the path were on
is about is about it's a narrative about
transcending the ordinary boring
unimpressive self that we were given
it's about becoming someone new it's
becoming a person capable of bliss or of
experiencing deep insights into the
nature of the universe or of stunning
the neuroscientists with the power of
their gamma waves or of rewiring our
brain so we become someone that we think
we would like better than we like our
parent selves namely a happier person or
maybe a much more compassionate person
and I think that these deep tensions in
the ways we can see the aspirational
task of self fashioning through
meditation are really important I think
they're important ethically and they're
important practically because they raise
serious questions about the goals of our
projects around human human
that we may not quite always be
discussing it has nuance the way as we
should they're also important
conceptually because they help us to see
continuities and also discontinuities in
the various projects around meditation
in our culture that otherwise might not
be so clear the connections between the
blissed-out TM practitioners on the one
side the rewired brains of these happy
monks on the other side my friends in
the mindfulness movement Richie Davidson
habits in don't like TM they would feel
very uncomfortable with what I've just
said that there are deeper historical
aspirations and common aspirations in
these projects that have not been
properly worked through if it makes them
uncomfortable it's all the more reason
that they should be surfaced and
discussed so I've kind of said
everything on my mind
my mind about all this I call these sort
of my final unfinished reflections but I
know that many of you will have your own
thoughts I my goal in these last few
minutes was begin to just open up the
bigger conversation not to wrap it up so
why don't I stop here for this awful six
o'clock and we can have a chat thank
[Applause]
so I have a mic for people who want to
ask questions because it's being filmed
not to broadcast but for posterity so I
will run around yes that's our children
yes Pete does before you talk I said are
you going to tell us about the mind and
you said well I'm a historian of mind
I'm not going to tell you about the mind
but actually when you write when you
describe the history as you did so
wonderfully today you are facing the
question what these people thought about
the mind and so thank you would be just
point well maybe well don't thank until
I finished all right because what what
they do throughout all this if I can
just generalize it so to get it of
course in a short time is they believe
in the validity of the generalizations
or the conceptualizations of something
called meditation of something called
mind of something called happiness some
all the all the terms that you found
there reflector using in the history you
recounted and the last thing that makes
it of more general malfeasance is that
they then do an experiment either the
early experiments were on the heart as
you pointed out and the stress could be
released and therefore they have a
physical measurement of caught heart
attacks because of stress and the
connection is vague but there's totally
they say when it comes to the mind and
imaging experiments like you spoke about
at the end I'm very familiar with those
and they're in cognitive psychology they
assume that something is correct in the
way we think of the world and then they
say if I take these concepts that
Sep of working memory or what have you
intention a speck ssin love
commercialization all the variations on
conceptualization that we have and then
if we find a region of the brain which
gives an activation when that behavior
that were this concept of behavior is
touched one then we start subtly see
that we now have a physical
manifestation the existence of the
concept yeah and so you're saying a sort
of phrenology
so a sort of phrenology is you can point
that you know that you know we have this
sort of folk concept of happiness we
related to a bit of the brain and we
imagine somehow that the brain is
generating or the generator of this
cultural concept or the spoke concept is
that without your point and yes yeah I
couldn't to do so Sherrington back in
you know ancient times talked about the
fact that we know in the end the brain
is going to be parsed in two functional
units that we don't have any names for
and so you know we now you know it back
in the day we you know we're going to
localize language expressive language
receptive language and but language is a
concept that comes from everyday speech
and it may or may not map in any
coherent way on to specific process and
I think that's your point
thank it's very good point and I don't
disagree I'm again yeah I am quite
critical of but you know I think the
happiest man in the world thing was not
a great idea but it's my job in a sense
I think to simply try without excessive
editorializing to try to understand the
logic of these kinds of projects and why
they have residents and that's why we
need an interdisciplinary conversation I
you know I think that the scientific
critique is really really important and
so with understanding why people
find this powerful and white people how
this becomes a framework for new
projects that engage a lot of human
beings and so we should try to
understand why I probably want to say
that it is not that it may be used these
ideas may be used in properly but they
when they are put into test they are
shown not to be working thank you so I'm
under the assumption I'm under the
assumption that you probably also
studied tests at some point in like your
career as a story decides and I'm
wondering like you can also give the
audience a filler on that it like had
it's like cultural growth that's a taint
I'm yeah you know the early wave of
mindfulness so what about like s and
maybe my like my perception is like it's
this Americanized version of finding of
self I think it's a great question I
don't know whether or not people who
sampled TM also sampled s you know and I
haven't looked at the you know I haven't
tried to integrate that soap as far into
the way I think about this history but
it's sort of also as lost you know it's
a moment came and went and what
interests me about the the narrative
that I've what do you think it still is
it maybe I'm wrong you are you a
practitioner but so it's a great
question it's a great question and you
know if you were doing a more kind of
syncretic analysis of the 70s in the
marketplace of these kinds of treatments
and their interrelation you would want
to look at that but I was doing a kind
of a longitudinal arc so I was following
a kind of narrower path that's a really
good question
hi thank you for your talk I just let it
so it'd be the history that you've kind
of laid out it's really interesting
right so first they're sort of like this
or not it dependents on drugs but and
then this sort of like divergence away
from using chemical means and recently
when you look at Rolling Stone in GQ and
Forbes there's and the New Yorker right
there's all this talk about ayahuasca
retreats and micro dosing at work and
about what micro dosing at work using LC
and then also using potentially LSD and
meditative practices so do you sort of
see like this change at this point in
time coming back that is coming back
that's good I think it's a great
question too and you know I the problem
is a problem of history and the
difference in the history and sort of
running a lab is you and you can't kind
of control all the data inside so and
the world is constantly changing around
you and you try to like stabilize
something so you can say something that
Lisa can talk about and you you know and
if I gave this talk in a year I might
now have to talk to I might have to talk
somewhat differently about the issues
because world would have shifted so I
have been interested in the fact that
LSE is getting a look in at the
psychotherapeutic not so much as a model
psychosis the way it was in the 50s but
as a psychotherapeutic treatment again
and whether or not that will how where
that will go
it's an exciting historical question we
have to sort of wait a little longer I
think so I don't know but it's a good
watch this space kind of a point I'm
going to quickly take chairs prerogative
beside the same or a version of the same
question you can tell me it's not the
same question which is you began with
LSD and then LSD led because it was
instant then to this interest in the
stuff and then we come back at the end
to the idea that this stuff is medicine
so we began in a story that was medicine
yeah it went out on the streets it
became an obsession with mindfulness or
meditation and mindfulness and then it
was reinvented as medicine at the end of
the story was that always going to
happen like were they like was it always
because it began in this medical context
where it was something that was supposed
to be for medical uses and now we return
like it's just like what I was finding
written at the beginning in a way Oh
Mike
so well don't be I wouldn't be so
deterministic sorry I don't want to be
deterministic I mean is it in a sense
not at all surprising that this thing
that began with medicine ended with
medicine because that was in fact the
kind of origin story for the use of LSD
in the person well look I think that
there is more to the history of the
appropriation of meditation or the
embrace of meditation in American
culture than just LSD the reason I track
that is because that's the most and it
comes back with the thing about how you
do your method and you have they need if
you have a broader flap you talk about
other things I think that you know that
particular story goes T M and T M then
goes to Benson and Benson and go to cap
its in and they go some in so we can you
know we can but if you again just
stopped back at that time and you would
see that some of those folks who had
gone off I said a few people went off to
India at the time and some of them come
back and they set up for them centers or
mindfulness you know inside meditation
centers and that has their own influence
and that isn't medicalised so I think
the medicalization is the real
medicalization moment comes when the
decision is made to LSE become so
thoroughly dissociated from its medical
origins and it's so thoroughly now
associated with those crazy kids and
with their unsavory free loved lifestyle
and loud music and whatever people are
thinking it when it becomes dissociate
a--from that and it's secularized and de
stern eyes d oriental eyes what happens
though is there's a kind of reorient
realizing of the practice particularly
around the Tibetan story that in a way
that didn't happen with the LSD story
that you know is melded with the medical
so you get these strange apparently
confusing juxtaposition of values and
images you know monks in flowing robes
inside fMRI machines and you know the
validating the power of meditative
practice because their prefrontal lobes
are so metabolic more active than that
of us so what did it have to be a
medical that have to end up in medicine
them you know I don't even know what now
I I just sort of I try to just follow
the follow the path but I think then the
question about whether LSD is returning
to medicine and returning to the medal
is is interesting and whether or not
we're going to rediscover some of the
you know whether some of the
conversations that seem kind of silly to
us now about from that earlier era will
seem less so if we reimburse these
pharmaceutics is an interesting question
so again if we have to just sort of be
patient enough to be able to allow
things to come into focus I had more of
a cultural question of before the
widespread acceptance of the language of
mindfulness and meditation where at
least for me growing up into like a
Hindu family like the language of
meditation and achieving motion all this
is its own separate category from like
the self recognised idea that these are
just like physical benefits to
mindfulness meditation and all and I
kind of I mean at least from the
judeo-christian rejection of like other
religions as having these sort of like
practical benefits and considering like
Protestantism 'he's like integral
relationship between the self and god
and that sort of self introspective
relationship what is it i guess my
question is what is it about like the
judeo-christian rejection of like these
oriental views that that made it so that
benson and then kabat-zinn had two
completely secular eyes in that in that
way further oriental eyes these ideas
which in the east
there isn't that distinction between
scientific and religious like rational
and this sort of more spiritual this is
these are really such good questions you
guys asked me some of the texts to go
back to the history of colonialism right
into the idea you know that you know it
was sort of Christian Europeans who
colonized you know these countries with
Buddhism and Hinduism were dominant and
know they're I'm not I'm not a set of
students of I'm not a really just study
scholar so I'm going to tread a little
bit lightly here but
now there is then a need or felt need to
distinguish between the winds that are
you know some of them are core fights
more Catholic because they're very there
the Catholic versions of Buddhism for
example because they're all ritual and
superstitious and there's more
Protestant ones that are kind of modern
modernizing when so Buddhism modernizes
and refrains itself as being about
mindfulness and about practice currently
in response to efforts by Christian /
Christian governments and people who
have colonized these countries to
eradicate them they have to reinvent
themselves through the history about the
modernization of Hinduism and Buddhism
that are important here there is then
you know the idea that it isn't just I
don't think it's just that the
Christians don't like please Leakey
Eastern things and so I can't use the
word I can't talk about monks and I
can't I don't think it's just that I
think it's more about the ways in which
these Eastern tropes become associated
with the cultural excesses of the 1960s
and a kind of sense that it was all kind
of justice these flaky crazy kids and
nothing respectable came and I think
it's more that that more that reaction
very few people that would come to
Jacobins clinics had whatever not what
didn't know anything you know they never
opened the Vita you know they had no
knowledge and they hadn't read these
folks you know but they knew about know
they know about monks and shaved heads
and so it's more the cultural props of a
discredited or allegedly discredited
project that he's trying to get away
from does that help that answer thank
you hi first just thank you really
interesting story in the 70s when the
theme was tuning down with meditation I
saw some similarities between the
prescription of meditation then and the
prescription of drugs like Milltown
prozac based drugs to unhappy housewives
in the 50s and 60s I'm wondering if
there is any feminist critiques of
meditation as if you're a question
prescribing it to housewives to make
them
background of it you know so it's a very
different era right I don't want the
shortages I don't think so
and just excite liege I'll come back to
Middletown but they know there was a
argument about Prozac that was made that
as a feminist drug because in contrast
to just sort of sedating the Housewives
so they could carry on with their
useless lives plagued by the problem
that has no name and you know the Prozac
I've got women into the workplace and
help them get the promotion and help
them to stand up even when they didn't
feel confident to their male colleagues
so Peter Kramer actually talks about it
in his book listen it occurs I guess a
feminist drug the feminist critiques of
the anti tranquilizers are it's a
product of the 60s you know and you know
I don't read I don't know whether or not
the TM moment when the housewives are
signing up lasted long enough or had
quite enough sort of you know cultural
depth to yet to warrant or to attract
that kind of critique but I like the
question and I think that I'm around you
know the critiques of mindfulness you
know where the place of gender could or
should fit into what we want to say
about the mindfulness phenomenon is a
really interesting thing and we're
thinking about um thanks for such a rich
talk I'm really wondering what role the
allure of the East plays within all of
this because if we weren't to cut across
meditation religiously as you're be
secular towards your secularization
story goes but instead philosophically
and bracket the East might it look
different I mean at least in the Western
tradition meta taught Co is to
contemplate philosophy students usually
encounter meditation first and des
cartes meditations on First Philosophy
it's not at all something anti rational
as the East would suggest orally connote
but instead something I'm deeply
rational might the history look
different than if you were to bracket
these well I think if you're a
philosopher you can bracket the
but if you're a historian you have to
sort of take the material as it comes
and now one of the things that actually
I just lost my train of thought
the know why I can't drag it but what I
actually I've had a have something I
want to say and notice okay let me just
repeat the question maybe I can remember
what I want to say so why you know if
also that this other point is that you
know Christians right now those are
their Christian traditions of
contemplation and but so I I do remember
what I wanted to say about about this
that I think the Mille arity breeds
contempt and this was our tradition and
it may be it's a kind of an other mind
story you know we want to go to the
unfamiliar because you know we maybe we
were raised in the type of church we
know the pre you know they're just
people but these other people who wear
these strange kinds of clothes and seem
to smile be typically and you know they
might be able to teach something to us
that you know it's at a level that we
couldn't get back home so I do think the
allure of the East while still is
practically not necessary might be
culturally if not necessary at least
highly you know highly motivating or
catalytic that would be my um hello
thank you for your talk my question is
about I guess like looking forward
considering other histories that you may
know so with like technology like cell
phones for example as like time
progresses like younger people are get
are exposed to or people are exposed to
them at earlier ages so what do you
think with as you know younger kids may
be around like 5 to like 7 in the future
start like taking up mindfulness like is
that something it that would be like
ultimately good or are there any
concerns that you know kids are very
moldable at that time of AIDS and you're
teaching them how to think are there any
concerns it's like corruption
and in that I would own a question
that's a great question and you
obviously or sounds like you're aware
that people are trying to do this that
they're bringing these techniques into
elementary schools and you know so what
do I you know though a few you've asked
me to have an opinion about it and I
don't mind having opinion I know I'm in
a pinch I um you know I think that um I
think it's important to be really kind
of mindful about all this you know if
you want to use that word so the idea is
that you know particularly kids who
might have trouble self-regulating who
might not be able to pay attention the
classroom who might previously have been
put on Ritalin or something because they
couldn't have now if they can
self-regulate and they can learn
techniques and they also might be also
less behavioral problems the question
may be is and I'm not yet might come
into the opinion but I'll first sort of
like who is this for is it for the kids
is it for the teachers is it for the
school-wide you know because these
children are not you know they're not
choosing to be transformed they're not
paying their money to go to TM class now
this is a imposed curriculum and if it
does feel more a social project than
like an individualist project and I
think that just means we need to sort of
think about that well now we do so so we
send kids to school we think everyone
needs to learn to read that we don't
find that offensive what do we think
that everyone should you know learn
these techniques what do I think yeah it
makes me a little bit nervous and I also
know what a good place it sort of comes
from I know that you know not all
parents so coming back to the non
deficit II of the eastern and yet how
difficult it is to extricate it some
parents of students who have been part
of these programs like a little bit you
know is this this may not be very
Christian or this is not part know how
is this consistent or not
with our values I know that there have
been some conversations about this but
do we think so if it's for the school or
for the teachers are we more were
troubled by that or less troubled by
that if it helps these kids sit better
learn better getting to get better
grades and abettor colleges are we is
that that make it sort of sort of okay
so I so maybe the you know answer is
let's if we can sort of pull out one of
the ethical issues and talk through the
you know the issues we can come to a
kind of ethical judgment rather than me
just sort of thing it's good as bad
because I think it's complicated we have
time for one more question anyone not to
do you practice mindfulness in your life
in like just what routine what kind I
did and I don't so I went through when
when I was part of an organization
called the MacArthur Network online body
interactions Richard Davidson as a
member of that I was the resident
humanist which meant I was responsible
for everything that didn't fit into a
laboratory and they decided that they
were going to do a study of the minds of
MBSR and we're going to use a group of
stressed-out executive and a biotech
company in Madison Wisconsin and I was
supposed to be the sort of the resident
let's think about the bigger picture
here guys person so I went through a
10-week its at the 8 week training
program cost additional two weeks
internship which they give to people who
are want to become teachers I went
through that program and actually found
it you know really quite powerful and I
also began to notice the first kind of
parody it's a stress reduction but were
laughing about how it's so stressful and
it's both in all the things that I
talked about I originally first
experienced in the in the classroom why
don't I do it anymore I do I think I
became a mother
and it kind of I decided that's my
practice actually I'm quite honest I
think if that's when I really sort of
gave it up I have gone on a couple of
silent retreats but never very long and
I just also what's happened to me and I
will now make it a pin you have an
opinion although you know because this
is a more about you know I think I have
pulled back from this world because I
have you know and I thought the point I
now have to sort of analyze this start
because I can no longer wholeheartedly
be an actor in the history is when I
also it isn't that I don't think
meditation might be useful I don't think
it intrinsically makes you more
compassionate I think that's a really
really dangerous thing and I remember
talking to a religious studies Buddhist
studies scholar named Robert scharff's
who studies Buddhism in Japan and he
says he do everything meditation makes
you more compassionate it depends what
you meditate on it's a you know and so
the I think people are being you know
enticed to believe this will save the
planet and that's a pity because these
smaller things that can do are also
really valuable and I wish we could be a
little more ordinary about it right but
you have to follow the cultural story
where it goes thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]